[Music]
the protests over the last two weeks
have tried tactics never seen before in
canada security was prepared to keep
trucks away on parliament hill but on
the streets of the city and at border
crossings ordinary life was brought to a
standstill the question is will
authorities be better prepared next time
because experts believe there will be a
next time
the first miscalculation was thinking
protesters would stay one weekend and
leave instead they turned their trucks
into urban barricades impossible to get
by or ignore
there was nothing that indicated that it
would be
this level of interference with the
normal way of life doug kirkland managed
security on parliament hill for years
nobody's seen a demonstration like this
before at the center of government
always a potential target security is
constantly evolving in 1989 a hijacked
bus was driven onto the hill a few years
later a man ran his jeep up the steps of
center block 911 prompted still tighter
security eventually parliament hill was
made off-limits to all but official
vehicles that at least may have kept
tractor trailers from steamrolling onto
the hill two weeks ago
but while parliament hill itself was
spared protesters sealed off the main
thoroughfare wellington street with
trucks and more trucks came and more
streets were blocked off protesters
choking off ordinary life in the city
for thousands of residents and not just
for one day the protests have definitely
created some new tactics that haven't
been seen in canada before and i think
that it's a tactic that we may see grow
it didn't take long for other small
groups to realize how easy it can be to
gum up canada's economic lifelines but
police learned too in toronto traffic
was steered away from queen's park the
optics of sticking a truck in the face
of government deflected in ottawa one
response could be as simple as putting
portable barricades in place sooner and
further out to discourage big rigs from
being used as big props but the issue in
the capital is also jurisdiction the
bureaucracies we certainly have them
stacked up on top of each other federal
municipal two provincial governments
different police forces it seems to take
so long for authorities to get together
to respond there's got to be a
streamlined table there has to be some
kind of interrelationship that can be
put together very quickly out of this
may come new laws that can be applied
quickly with heavier penalties
restrictions which could boomerang on
so-called freedom protests the irony of
the protests is they're actually
potentially going to limit freedoms in
the long run
still the protests unleashed new methods
and discovered new streams of funding on
social media by any measure one small
group showed just what is possible in
canada it may set a tone for what's to
come
but
this was the first